the risks that are necessary to be a
social entrepreneur to be an
entrepreneur who starts a company or
some combination of the two are the same
because if you want to introduce massive
change in a market or in society you
have to do things that challenge the way
that people act you have to make people
be uncomfortable that's the nature of
entrepreneurship altogether in terms of
coming up with a concept start with an
emotional commitment to something or an
intellectual belief that if you don't
pursue this the world will not be as
good as it might be or some customer
won't be served in the way that they
they should be whatever kind of personal
value comes out of that if it's
enrichment or you achieve some specific
aim
I think that's secondary to being very
specifically committed and usually the
people who I know who are monomaniacal
about doing something are much more
likely to be successful than people who
are merely concerned with trying to
become rich so fundal econ set is a
venture and it's a brand it started
about two years ago I was in Africa
working on a ethos project and met young
men who were armed with assault weapons
and started to think about the
implications of that and John my
business partner was in Tanzania
visiting a conference and then going out
and meeting entrepreneurs and was
thinking about making investments saw
the same kinds of problems and started
to think about the risk that was
involved in making investments where
people had guns and so the two of us
started talking about that and we
decided that we would try to do
something that was transformative and
that conversation evolved into foundry
47 and what we do is take a que 47s from
war zones in Africa we transform the
material into raw steel and then we
partner with exceptional designers to
make jewelry and watches and accessories
that are sold at the top end of each of
those markets and then funding that's
generated from those is then invested in
weapon destruction and youth leadership
programs back in Africa and so our main
focus in terms of what we want this
venture to do is to significantly reduce
the
number and impact of assault weapons in
Africa that probably doesn't begin with
a number as a target but it begins with
a mindset and sort of thinking about
what do you have to get people to start
feeling and thinking and doing to move
in the direction of saying there should
be a target and so helping people to
understand how these weapons play a role
in Africa's problems how they enable a
lot of the fear they enable things like
poaching grape they enable genocide they
enable conflict at a scale that's much
greater than Africa knew before they
were present and I think if we can draw
down some of the numbers and demonstrate
that it's possible and show people what
kind of difference it makes and in
someone's life that weapons are being
removed then we can start to attract
interest from other funders from other
NGOs from international organizations
and ultimately from governments who will
see this as a way of facilitating
stability and ultimately higher economic
activity ethos water and fundal accounts
that they challenge people in very
specific ways they challenge thinking
they challenge people who are on lots of
different points of political and
economic perspectives and trying to do
something that's revolutionary or that
will be significantly disruptive to the
way that people think and act and
purchase doesn't begin with an idea that
immediately is accepted it wouldn't make
any sense
you